[Music]
so let's talk about Charlie Hebdo for a
little bit because I think that the
reaction to Charlie Hebdo was really
what my final straw was wit sort of the
progressive movement because I saw so
many people so many people saying they
shouldn't have done these cartoons they
focused on Islam it turned out that it's
something it was something like 3% of
the covers about Islam I use I was on a
show actually on a network where
somebody said it was 99% of the covers I
didn't have the information right in
front of me but I said I'm pretty sure
that's not the case but just the knee
jerk and defense and almost no there was
almost it was like there would be a line
of well these people are dead but then a
tirade on the left of don't do this
don't do this especially here was it was
it more here do you think yes I think so
I mean you had this event in New York
American Penn wanted to award yeah you
to reward Charlie to for courage and a
lot of famous writers didn't want to
show up because they they they didn't
believe that they deserve this kind of
award what and and a lot of a lot of
American left-wing intellectuals just
got it wrong yeah because they see look
at this through the lens of race and
this is not about race and it turns out
the Charlie Doe in fact have been the
staunchest defender of Muslims as a weak
minority yeah friends most of the covers
we can Charlie Hebdo were were mocking
not Muslim people they were mocking the
dogmatic parts of the religion that are
oppressing Muslim people the Pope I mean
if you look at what they did to the Pope
I mean what they did to the to the
Prophet is just like a kindergarten very
sexually explicit cartoons of of the
Pope but but mostly they were in fact
marking powerful politicians like
Sarkozy or lepen
and in business magnets and and and
mechanisms and things like that it was
it was seven covers I guess out of
around five hundred that dealt with
Islam and the Prophet so so it's it's
just plain wrong
[Music]
no I but but but it is true that in
France you have this anti-clerical
tradition on the left because a very
tough battle with the Catholic Church
for many many years and it has played
over into the way they look at the
religion in in general but they they
they they they criticize and attack the
Catholic Church far more than they
criticize and attack Islam yeah do you
think that when people are doing this
when they're saying well don't don't
offend them don't offend them they
realize do you think at some level some
of them realize the actual bigotry that
they're showing which you know george w
bush came up with the phrase the soft
bigotry of low expectations yes which
now film are used a lot in plenty of
other people it's bizarre i guess maybe
that it came from george w bush but to
me that like it will really it was a
speechwriter of his they came up with it
he got it out there but now it seems so
obvious to me that that's what's
happening here's what you say racism of
loic's pictures yeah what you're saying
is well you can mock christianity
because they have a sense of humor they
can deal with it they'll be alright
they're grown-ups they're grown-ups but
if you mock islam well then if you get
shot or somebody blows something up you
know it was sweet discriminating against
muslims because you look at them as if
they are animals or children they can't
handle this like other believers and
people can and that's really
discriminating is that the saddest part
for you that what you did in 2005 wasn't
based in humor but actually Charlie
Hebdo was based in great satire and
humor and as he said I mean France has
an incredible tradition of satire that
if we don't allow these people not allow
them they should have the same right
that everyone else has to make fun of
their own institutions and we should be
able to make fun of them and they should
be able to make fun or
if we don't allow them we're actually
robbing them of what is perhaps the most
important thing that you can have is a
human because that's real freedom yes
and and in fact I have heard some of my
Muslim friends talk that way that we
need hundreds of Charlie up doors in the
Muslim world because religion is really
being used as a as a tool of oppression
and and and and Christians can laugh at
themselves because there is this freedom
in fact for many Christians within their
religion that they can they can they can
listen to a dirty joke about the Virgin
Mariah yeah without being you know feel
that they have been attacked or because
there is a sense of freedom I always say
that the example I always use is that do
you ever see the show Family Guy it's
speaking I don't know if it's big in
Denmark but there's it mocks everybody
in relentlessly they do plenty of there
was an episode where they had they went
back to you know Bethlehem mm whatever
2,000 years ago and they have Jesus
bathing to porn music and a little baby
walks in and watches him but you need
that satire because that's ridiculous or
you could watch Curb Your Enthusiasm and
every episode is Larry David making fun
of Jesus that and the for my edits are
chargeable to I think put it in a very
eloquent way he said you know what kind
of civilization are we if we cannot mock
make fun and ridicule the religion in
which name trains airplanes and people
are being blown up I think in fact
satire is a very civilized reaction to
violence you don't respond for violence
you laugh you make people laugh
and and that is in a way it's a way of
of managing a difficult situation and I
I think it is very civilized I mean when
when when when Charlie Hebdo or when our
cartoons were published it was a
reaction to to to violence intimidation
and threats in the public space we did
not respond in kind but we said okay
let's have some fun yeah
and and I think I think it's a big it's
a big challenge for from Muslims to work
out a relationship to their faith where
it is possible to make fun without
feeling you know that your faith is
being undermined that it makes you it
helps you to create a distance that is
based in freedom and that that the
Prophet Muhammad and the crown is not
being used to oppress you or control you
socially but there also is an element of
freedom and free choice when when you
have the the the ability to laugh yeah
I'm trying to get to a part in this
where we can start spinning this in a
way that'll be positive for society so
I'm with you on all the philosophic
precepts you've laid out I'm completely
with you but at the same time you're
saying yeah you think that the the we're
not going the far right but those
parties those right parties or the
anti-immigration parties let's say are
going to keep gaining strength I suspect
that that type of populism will continue
happening in America the next time that
there's a bad terrorist attack in any of
these countries now we live in a global
world it's going to increase those
numbers so is there a silver lining here
I mean I know that I know that there's a
middle growing here I think that we're
part of but is there some sort of
political piece of that yeah I say I
think I think my problem was what you
hold a populist right is that they
believe that we are at war with Islam
and and and most Muslims in fact buy in
to this determination of violence in the
name of their religion I don't I don't
believe that's the case and I believe
that we have to be very clear about
definitions I think we are at in a hot
ball with jihadists people who are
killing and committing violence and I
believe we are in a cold war with
Islamists who are not using violence but
believe in the tenets of
a very anti-democratic anti-freedom
ideology which means that we need to
find believing Muslims not APIs that's
not former Muslims but but true
believers who subscribe to the values of
liberal democracy the secular state
freedom of speech freedom of religion
because I don't I believe this is a
basically a battle of ideas and we
cannot win this battle of ideas if we do
not have true believers among Muslims on
our side so we had to we had to start
looking for them and I may be man Majid
Navas whom you mentioned I don't know if
his tailor believing Muslims but at
least he used to be I I have a I have a
dialogue with a Norwegian Muslims who
wrote a book is it possible to love the
Koran and Norway at the same time and I
like that book because he's very clear
about the fact that free speech and
freedom of religion is not off for
negotiations at the same time he's a
socially conservative Muslim we disagree
on most things right but but but I think
we agree on the fundamentals of secular
democracy yeah and that's exactly where
we have to find these people do you
think that there are enough of them
because my my fear is yet we know that
there are 1.3 billion Muslim people
that's a lot of people but the problem
is that they that a lot of them have
been sort of chilled they've been afraid
to say what they speak because of all of
it because they're getting it from both
sides right if they if they speak about
it then the more conservative it
certainly the Islamists are gonna be
angry at them and if they speak about it
they know that they're gonna be treated
as from the left they know they're gonna
be treated like they were sellouts to
their own community or something so this
is a really narrow group of people that
we have to try to security on the uphill
struggle and I believe that Islam is in
a deep crisis and it will take decades I
think to fight out this ideological
where you have to work out a religious
doctrine that is compatible compatible
with a multi-religious multicultural
democracy it's not going to be easy and
we have to be honest about that I also
think it doesn't help when Western
politicians say that the jihadist they
have just taken Islam hostage that this
has nothing to do with Islam yeah it has
and take their word for it that's what I
mean I mean am I to tell them that it's
not okay one of the reasons why it's
this battle is so difficult is because
the jihadist in fact they stand on a
strong theological ground there are
phrases and verses in the Koran that
justify violence against non-believers
against the blasphemers against epithets
and they have this utopia that they want
to recreate the Caliphate the time of
the Prophet Mohammed and the first
caliphs after the Prophet and and and
and and if you say this has nothing to
do with Islam you never get into this
battle of ideas and it's clear when you
when when you talk to Muslims that they
feel they feel very intimidated by the
theological arguments being used by the
jihadists and and for you and me it may
it may it it doesn't sound intimidating
when people you know tell me if Flemming
you're a bad Christian or they tell you
that you're bad you yeah whatever it is
but if you can finally attack if you if
you say to a Muslim you are a bad Muslim
it feels very intimidating so so so we
should not we should not refrain from
you know getting into this fight and
acknowledge that you had is in fact do
make reference to the Quran that and
there is a tradition within Islam that
is violent and that wants to kill Apple
stats and blasphemers
and so on and so forth do you think that
some of the apologists are strangely
misguided so for example during this
whole thing with the executive order and
Trump and the refugees
I saw a few very popular people on
Twitter people with millions of
followers tweeting things to the effect
of you know how you get terrorists you
ban all people from your country and it
does go to the soft bigotry of low
expectations again because it's saying
wait a minute if you don't let everyone
in well then they might start blowing
themselves up or blowing you up like
there it's almost as if the logic is in
thought out so what we really need is a
resurgence of logic more than anything
exactly and we had to be very clear that
the people who commit violence are
responsible violence not Donald Trump
top Barrack Obama or under a miracle
it's the people who commit violence and
quite often I also experience that
during the Khartoum crisis people will
accuse me of being responsible for
violence in other parts of the world
which is which is a slippery slope
if you if you open that door it never
stops you have to be very clear that an
individual we we have reason we have a
mind as human beings to make a decision
about how to react to other people
speech and cartoons and it means that we
are responsible agents not not not not
people who offends us or say something
offensive and and I also think that we
had to educate ourselves about Islam I
mean I didn't know that there was pain
on images of the Prophet 11 years ago
and I had a crash course I would say did
you really have no idea and when you did
that and no one said to you as we're
gonna do it nobody not-not-not in that
specific way and I didn't hear about it
until afterwards but it turned out that
there were voices inside the newspaper
that it didn't make any sight warning
but they said Suzy at essentia that we
should be cautious but I never I never
got that word and I don't think it
matter that much
because that's not the way with sweet
ideas in in in the way you shouldn't
consult you know lawyers and eggs I mean
you can consult a lawyer if you want to
know what you want to pop this is legal
right but otherwise you have to make a
decision for yourself whether you think
it's legitimate and and and and makes
sense but I think we we we all know too
little about Islam and and when people
say this has nothing to do with Islam
they they they really don't know the
history of Islam and what had been done
and not done in the name of of the
Prophet throughout history yeah I almost
feel like I don't know that we have to
know more about Islam we have to know
more about what our Western values are
and maybe it may be both of those things
at the same point but I would rather
people focus on that absolutely I agree
100% and that is one of the reasons why
we are not facing up to that challenge
we have forgot we have forgotten who we
are where we come from and what what
what
what is the foundation of our success in
the West yeah I've heard you say that
you don't regret publishing the cartoons
and and you know when people ask me
would you do it again it's usually I say
you know when if if I say I would not do
it again I will send a very unfortunate
signals to the people who come into
violence yeah and basically to say to
them if you if your frettin enough if
you're killing off people I will do
exactly as you please so why stop yeah
and that's the message that all my
friends on the Left are sending to them
all the time every time you say it don't
publish a dope oh well what else we know
they don't like gay marriage so should
we not have an it gay marriage we know
they whatever else they don't like
whatever else were in we're pushing on
them of our secularism should we just be
as hostages to all of that and that and
that's why we have also forgot that free
speech is important to minorities if you
look at social movements throughout
history women's rights workers rights
gay rights black the civil rights
movement they all benefit us from free
speech without without freedom of
expression they could
not have gone all the way they've gone
and the powers that be in that time they
they used hate speech laws blasphemy
laws to silence these social movements
for change but today it it's as if
people have forgotten that history that
in fact freedom of speech is paramount
to minority movements and eg vigils who
are fighting for social change yeah so I
have one more question for you which I
think wraps this all up perfectly which
goes to the email that I get more than
anything else which is people tell me
all the time they're afraid to say what
they think not not because they're gonna
be killed by a jihadist necessarily but
because they don't want to be called a
bigot or whatever they don't want to be
defriended on Facebook or any of that
stuff so as someone who truly in the
scheme of things I mean you have been
right in the center of this this is your
life for for now on what what's the I
think you've made the argument already
but what's the best organ you can get
from a personal thing cuz I would
imagine the personal toll has probably
been quite great you said you have to
live with certain security measures and
things like that but what's the best
argument you can make of why we need
more people no I think you have I mean
it's not nice to be called a bigot and
the Nazi and the fascist whatever but
but you have to think through your own
position and when I was faced with that
challenge I was very surprised because I
didn't have the intentions that people
ascribe to me so I really had to think
through what I believe in and and and go
through my experiences you know the
people I admire the books I read the
principles I wanted to live my life in
accordance with and I ended up
reinforcing my own conviction that that
was the right thing to do and that I was
willing to defend those principles you
you you and and and then you had
sustained by you know what you believed
in and just keep on explaining yourself
and then hope at some point people will
get it if they don't maybe in a
generation and two there will be people
who read your stuff and think oh yeah I
didn't think about that that's
that's true and and and you know that's
the way I look at it now I have
grandkids and I'm starting to think
about what my country and Europe will
look like in in 30 40 50 years and I see
my contribution not so much as something
that is going on right now I'm sure that
that future generations will face some
of some of the same challenges at some
point and and so I hope that they can go
back and and and read about my story and
hopefully learn a lesson or two
yeah well that's a perfectly fitting
ending we're gonna be speaking at UCLA
tomorrow although the time this by the
time this video has gone up we'll have
done it already
but I love the idea of getting in front
of some young minds and just putting it
out there and then hopefully they pick
up on some of it some of them may be
angry at us but but it's been a pleasure
talking to you and you guys can find out
more about Fleming and check out his new
book tyranny of silence at tyranny of
silence net
[Music]
you